Humans are really good at pattern
recognition.
We use it in nearly every aspect of our
lives.
Recognizing people,
knowing a song by the first few bars and
the list is endless and in some cases
pattern recognition involves taking
existing empirical evidence to find
trends and project future think the
weatherman.
Now the problem for humans is we often
get it wrong.
We overemphasize some facts,
make big judgments based on too small of
data sets,
but technology is changing.
All of this just as technology changed
your ability to make an informed
decision on which type of barriers best
black bear.
It's also going to augment and improve
our abilities to make statistically
sound decisions based on the patterns of
millions of other humans.
Some of these augmentations have already
happened and can be examined.
This is how Netflix can create a list of
what you want to watch next based on
your viewing history and millions of the
other people's history.
These augmentations also help Amazon
know what you want to buy next and these
are all good and pretty benign forms of
statistical profiling,
but there are some implications to this
usage of big data.
They get uncomfortable.
And if you're prone to obsessing over
moral dilemmas,
you might want to skip this one.
So let's dive into this.
Here's a hypothetical.
Let's say in the US,
the number one priority is to stop the
listening and proliferation of
nickelback.
And after years of nickelback fans
slipping through the cracks,
they notice something.
It seems that 90% of all known offenders
had green hair.
Now us humans doing as we do,
we say,
hey,
we only have so many policing resources.
Let's focus it all on these nickelback
loving green haired people.
Now this might be more effective,
but the question is,
should justice break its commitment to
impartiality to be more effective?
Because out of a million green haired
people search,
maybe only one has nickelback CD.
So even though the likelihood of a
nickelback fan having green hair is 90%
the likelihood of someone green hair
like nickelback is 0.01%
so is it right to accuse someone of
atrocious music tastes just based on the
trait of green hair?
Well,
most people,
including myself,
would say no,
of course not.
Whether someone likes nickelback on only
one trait creates an astronomical error
margin.
So it's easy to focus on individual
rights and justice being blind and all
that.
But this is the problem.
This error margin is going to get much
smaller soon.
The digital image of each individual is
getting clearer and more nuance and
we're starting to use ai to sift through
big data to find patterns of human
behavior too large for humans to see on
their own.
So what happens when the s in Iaa is
99.9%
sure that you like nickelback based on a
hundred factors including such things as
your spotify history of listening to
nineties rock bands,
frequent attendance of post grunge
festivals and that Mega douchebag
haircut.
So what do we do then?
Suddenly a lot of questions open up,
but it is nonetheless profiling based on
circumstantial evidence.
Are we allowed to get a search warrant
for his house based on this?
To what extent are we willing to let law
enforcement use modern data to catch
criminals?
This is a problem that the justice
system is going to,
to grapple with soon.
And I'm not sure we're prepared to deal
with the change in thinking that it
might require,
nor am I sure that there is a correct
answer.
So let's leave our nickelback scenario.
Sorry,
nickelback fans and back into the real
world for a second.
What happens when the justice system is
99.9%
sure that this guy is going to shoot up
a school?
Next step,
do we lock him up before he's committed
the crime and how do we weigh the
individual's right to innocence until
proven guilty against the collective
desire for safety?
And if you for one second think this
isn't a modern problem for us,
considered this,
both the Orlando shooter and London
terrorists were both profile to be known
risks before they attack.
As our risk assessments become more
accurate is their moral culpability if
we don't act on this information,
this uncomfortable dilemma is starting
to pop up more and more and it's not
going to go away.
No,
I'm like most of my videos where I make
some final opinion on the issue.
I really don't know the answer to this
question,
but what I do know for sure it is
technology has augmented our ability to
recognize patterns and digitally profile
people more effectively than ever.
And this might change the justices
some forever.
You know what they say?
If you could do good things for other
people,
you had a moral obligation to do those
things.
That's what's at stake here,
not choice.
We sponsored that.
Thank you guys so much for watching that
video.
It was a blast to make and I want to
hear it from you in the comments below
what you think about it.
Do you think technology will change the
justice system and just let me know your
takeaway from the video.
So if you liked that video,
you can subscribe or watch another video
here and I make new videos every
Wednesday,
so I hope to see you then.